this presentation focuses on registering
and preparing for the associate cloud
engineer certification exam as you
prepare for your careers in a cloud
first world there's no better time for
you to get certified certification is
essential in today's market to validate
mastery and competency of technologies
that are critical to business's success
certification provides credibility and
Industry recognition it is a testament
to your skills and proficiency in Google
cloud platform certification is a formal
recognition of professionals who meet
established knowledge skills or
competencies certification often gives
you a competitive advantage over
somebody who is not certified
certification ensures that you are on
top of Industry and technology
developments and that your skills are
updated in 2013
70% of IT professionals believe that
certifications lead to a more effective
staff that number is well above 90%
today one of our partners who took the
training and certifications told us GCP
certification proves that an engineer
not only has real-world experience but
also has the technical knowledge to
operate at the level required the
associate cloud engineer track includes
the associate cloud engineer
certification this certification is an
entry point to a career in cloud and to
Google cloud certification the associate
cloud engineer certification assesses
your technical knowledge including the
ability to plan deploy and ensure
successful operation of a cloud solution
professional level certifications
identify individuals who are capable of
work that is critical to modern
technology initiatives we make sure that
these certification exams actually
validate role related skills they don't
just assess technical requirements but
also assess how you map business
requirements to solutions developed
using Google cloud hands-on practice is
critical to success exams must be taken
at a criterion authorized test center
register early as test center
availability is limited questions can be
multiple choice or multiple select you
can go back and review earlier questions
at any time during the exam no paper
pens or pencils are allowed during
testing in professional exams when
answering there might be several options
that seem correct
but there is only one option that
satisfies both technical and business
requirements choose the best even if the
others might work we are testing for
Google best practices with Google cloud
certification you can differentiate
yourself from your peers you also have
the opportunity to network and exchange
ideas in the Google cloud certified
community review the exam guide to
understand the scope of the exam
complete all courses in the architecting
with Google cloud platform
specialization spend sufficient time to
watch the videos complete all hands-on
labs and review related documentation in
order to fully learn concepts and
practice working with Google cloud
platform hands-on experience is critical
to success practice with additional
hands-on labs in the quick labs platform
complete the self-paced labs in the
cloud architecture quest and GCP
essentials quest you can also complete
additional labs on related topics note
that you can complete these labs free of
charge
check previous communication sent to you
with quick labs credits information
assess your knowledge by taking the
associate cloud engineer practice exam
you can take the practice exam any
number of times
register early for a certification exam
at the nearest criterion testing center
you can find a criterion Testing Center
using the locator website shown here